وكالة الانباء الجزائري عن رئيس
مجموعة الطاقة الوطنية سوناطراك
الولايات المتحدة لاوكرانيا.
وتتركز تلك المخاوف على مصير هذه
المصري باستقباله. العالم لا
تنقصه الكوارث لكن بعض الدول
غير قصد والمتضرر اولا واخيرا هي
الدول الضعيفة والفقيرة. كيف
الاسلحة وما اذا كان من الممكن
تلك الاسلحة لاطراف خطأ فهل يقل
وصول امير قطر الى مصر بعد سبع
سنوات من الفرقة والغياب والرئيس
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعلنون
موافقتهم على ترشح كل من
اليمن برنامج الغذاء العالمي
يعلق انشطته في اليمن. وقال انه
المقاومة الفلسطينية اللبنانية
المشتركة على الكيان الاسرائيلي؟
من جانب اخر رحلات تجارية
اماراتية تهبط في مطارات وترفع
اجتمع اسماعيل هنية وحسن نصر
الله لمناقشة تهديدات اسرائيل
نقص الذي فاقمت حدته الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية ودعا جوتيريش
عراق على ايدي جنود بولنديين على
الجانب البولندي من الحدود مع
طائرات بكين التي حلقت في سماء
تايوان تقول للامريكان ان الصين
والتعاون بما يخدم القضية
الفلسطينية. فبماذا سترد
انه يعتزم التحدث الى نظيره
الصيني في وقت يدرس احتمال رفع
اربعين دولة على الاجتماع في
المانيا. فهل تفلح هذه الدول في
اوكرانيا ومولدوفا لعضوية
الاتحاد وواشنطن تعلن عن مساعدة
على هذه الحادثة. فما الذي سيرد
به الزعيم الروسي? وعلى من سيرد
جونسون ازمة الغذاء العالمية هي
ازمة افتعلها بوتين والمملكة
الامريكي لتصنيف روسيا كدولة
راعية للارهاب. كارثة انسانية في
لتكون في متناول الرئيس الروسي
في كل الاوقات وتحتوي على اجهزة
النووية التي ترافق زعيم
الكرملين دائما. ويرقد زمن في
المتحدة خصصت موازنة بحوالي
ثلاثمائة وخمسين مليون جنيه
موطنا للعديد من المصانع
الكيماوية. اعتبر وزير الخارجية
الذي اعلنه بوتريش لن يكون اي
بلد في مأمن. ما هذا الذي تقوله
دولة اوروبية والاتحاد الاوروبي
رصد ثلاثمائة مليار يورو لتنويع
استرليني لتعزيز الامن الغذائي
العالمي. دعوات في الكونجرس
تزيد الكوارث العالمية اكثر
واكثر سواء اكان ذلك بقصد او عن
الماضي. من اهم مدن اقليم لوغنسك
الانفصالي شرقي اوكرانيا. وقد
تخترق اجواء تايوان مجددا تركة
تهديدات واشنطن خلفها؟ والجزائر
بحاجة لمليار ونصف المليار دولار
لمواجهة المتطلبات الانسانية في
قوله ان من المتوقع ان يرتفع دخل
الجزائر من صادرات النفط والغاز
الامم المتحدة؟ ولماذا كل هذا
العويل؟ انحن امام كارثة حقا؟
الارهابية الى الدول الاوروبية
ويكتشاف تسرب كبير في الاسلحة
ستنجو هذه الدول?
الرابعة. الداخلية التونسية تعلن
احباط محاولة اغتيال للرئيس قيس
الى ساحات وبلدان اخرى وباسعار
اقل مما بيعت به بكثير ايضا حالة
الصادرات قد بلغ خمسة وثلاثين
مليار اربعمائة دولار في العام
وقاسية جدا. تكليف نجيب ميقاتي
بتشكيل الحكومة اللبنانية للمرة
الدعم الامريكي لكييف بعد هذا
كله? الاحداث والتطورات. نقلت
اوضح الزيلينسكي ان سقوط يعني
سقوط دومبس وتعد سيفيرو الدونسك
والولايات المتحدة تصدر قرارا
زلزل الوسط الامريكي. حامل
اما تركيا فتضع يدها على يد
اسرائيل وتعمل على حماية
الازمة. صدمة عراقية. صدمة وذهول
في العراق مؤخرا. بعد نشر تقارير
الارهاب الاسرائيلي في فلسطين يا
احفاد عثمان؟ قلق غربي. ازمة
الاسرائيليين في انقرة خوفا من
رد ايران عليهم. وماذا عن
من اقتصاد تل ابيب فما الذي
تريده الامارات بدعمها لاسرائيل؟
الاوكرانية وارتفاع اسعار الحبوب
اليمن يواجه خطر مجاعة كارثية
باستخدام الجوع سلاح حرب محذرة
ما وصفته بتسونامي المجاعة. ونفت
اتهمت المانيا على لسان وزيرة
الخارجية انالينا بيربوك روسيا
العاصمة مينيسك ادلة ومعلومات عن
اعدامات جماعية وسرية للاجئين
اليمن خلال ستة اشهر قادمة ويعلن
البرنامج ذلك بسبب الحرب الروسية
اسرائيل تهدد باجتياح لبنان
وتتوعد حزب الله بدفع ثمن باهظ.
العام للامم المتحدة انطونيو
غوتيريش من كارثة عالمية جراء
امنية جديدة لكييف قدرها اربع
وخمسون مليون دولار. بوريس
مصادر امداد اوروبا بالغاز
ولتقوية البنية التحتية. زعماء
الوقاية من السلاح الذي يستخدمه
بوتين ضدهم? فيما حذر الامين
كارثة انسانية قاسية فمن ينقذه?
احباط محاولة اغتيال رئيس تونس
الاوروبية امدادات الغاز الروسي
الى اوروبا توقفت لاثنتي عشرة
الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان بلاده لن
تقدم جديدا في المفاوضات مع
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان الكرة في
ملعبهم الان. رئيسة المفوض
جديدة في اوروبا والعالم. يدق
ناقوس خطرها بعد الخشية من تسرب
تفيد بان لجنة تحقيق في
بيلاروسيا سلمت وفدا عراقي يزور
مزاعم موسكو بان تكون العقوبات
التي تفرضها المجموعة السبع هي
من الخوف اصابت كثيرين من حجم
الاسلحة الهائلة التي تقدمها
الحقيبة النووية. اصابة حامل
حقيبة الرئيس الروسي النووية
التي يتم شحنها الى اوكرانيا
ويتم بيعها في الاسواق السوداء
خمسين مليار دولار بنهاية الفين
واثنين وعشرين. بعد ان كان حجم
قطر يعود الى مصر بصفحة جديدة
بعد قطيعة لسنوات صدمة عراقية
باسم الخارجية الامريكية قوله ان
على بكين ان توقف انشطتها
العناية المركزة في المستشفى.
حقيبة بوتين النووية شيجيت صممت
الدبلوماسية والعسكرية وما سماه
بالضغط الاقتصادي على تايوان لكن
الامريكية على التعاون في حال
التصعيد مع لبنان. هل وصلت رسالة
اللبنانيين لاسرائيل لتسبب هذه
التصريحات؟ وبعد تصريحات تل ابيب
يا ترى? بكين لا تخاف الحرب. في
احدث تصعيد للتوترات بين البلدين
اماراتية جديدة لفلسطين بينما لم
تشفى جروح الطعنات السابقة وامير
والجيش الاسرائيلي يجري تدريبا
عسكريا مع القيادة الوسطى
حامل حقيبة بوتين النووية يصاب
بالرصاص. فمن الذي يجرؤ على ذلك؟
يصدق كيان اسرائيل يتحالف مع
تركيا في الوقت الذي يهدد
برصاص مجهول في شقته بموسكو.
وبحسب صحيفة ميرورا البريطانية
تضاعف صادراتها من النفط والغاز
وتزيد من دخلها القومي بشكل لا
هذه هذا كل ما تستطيعون فعله
ايها العراقيون اسرائيل والعرب.
ولماذا يصر الروس على السيطرة
على يا ترى! قلق غربي وامريكي من
في الاثناء قادة الدول الغنية
لمساعدة الدول الفقيرة لتخفيف
بعض الرسوم الجمركية على بكين
لمجابهة التضخم تصريحات بايدن
تاتي بعد تصاعد التوتر بين
البلدين. الكارثة المرتقبة.
السبب في ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائية. الغذاء سلاح فتاك يجبر
لا فماذا انتم فاعلون؟ بينما
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بعد اعدام لاجئهم في بولندا فكيف
سترد بغداد واليمن يقف على شفا
ارسلت تايوان طائرات مقاتلة
لابعاد نحو تسع وعشرين طائرة
بيلاروسيا لكن الحكومة العراقية
شكلت لجنة لدراسة ازمة الاعدامات
صينية توغلت في المجال الجوي
لتايباي ونقلت رويترز عن المتحدث
اطلاق صواريخ الكرملين
الاستراتيجية. بوتين لم يرد بعد
فان العقيد السابق فادم زينين
كان مسؤولا عن حقيبة الضوء
باجتياح لبنان فهل يدرك الكيان
ما الذي يواجهه في بيروت وطعنة
بيع اسلحتهم في السوق السوداء؟
يا له من امر مضحك حقا! الصين
اعلنها الامين العام للامم
المتحدة فبسلاح روسيا الفتاك
كارثة عالمية على وشك الحدوث.
والعالم يقف قلقا مما يحدث هكذا